[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous video we have looked at
an alternative formulation
of the buckling theory and at the end of
that video we had said that how that
alternative formulation and the insights
came thereof
would help us to make some headway into
a more exact theory
so that more exact theory is uh is what
is going to lead us to the equation of
the elastica so uh this rather exotic
name is there because of some historical
reasons
uh it has been investigated for quite a
long time by mathematicians
so now so we'll respect that
that history and and name our
topic of discussion as the elastica okay
so
what we're going to do is to go back to
a certain point in that
alternative formulation pick an equation
from there
and proceed from there okay so
let's go back
so this is the first slide within our
previous video and we are what we are
going to pick out
is this particular equation at the end
of this slide
okay so let me just copy it
out
there are a number of disadvantages to
[Music]
using this writing app but one big
advantage
surely is uh is this copy paste business
that i'm allowed to do here
okay that saves certainly saves a lot of
time
okay the first thing that we're going to
do
is uh we're not going to consider this
kind of a lateral force okay so
that is zero
let me write that on a better fashion
all right uh with that out of the way
what i'll do is i'll just repeat this
thing
uh the left hand side remaining as it is
but the right hand side
uh
right inside that i will rewrite
as
0 to l t
um delta
t w d x whole square okay
i believe no one should have any problem
with me writing this as this
okay all right so what i'll do is
i'll take this the plan is like this so
i'll take up this
left hand side and this right hand side
separately and then
i'm going to utilize whatever
insights i have obtained previously as
well as
my my knowledge about the geometry
to uh to go
from this version of the equation to a
more exact version
okay so the first step towards that
towards that goal is to identify that
in the left hand side what i have this
d square w dx square that
term is basically an approximation of
the curvature of the beam
okay so we have we have mentioned this
earlier in a in a previous video
that
and this basically follows from our
knowledge of first
engineering mathematics where we talked
about uh curvature of
uh of a general curve uh
so d squared w d x square is
an approximation
of the curvature of the beam
which is uh
if you refer to your first year
engineering mathematics books
uh you will you will note that the
general formula for the curvature
is given by this
the whole thing is within a three by two
power
all right so what we have what we
basically say is that if dw dx is not
too large
uh compared to one uh then or is rather
small compared to one
then uh this entire term it basically
reduces
to d squared w d x square approximately
okay so now we want to go uh
from in the in the reverse direction
that so we identified that this
indeed is an approximation of this and
that is
the that is the curvature of the beam so
uh how could we rewrite
this term using that knowledge that it
is indeed the curvature
okay so that is the question we pose to
ourselves
okay so what we do is
as we have done in the previous video we
are going to go
from this um this xz coordinate system
uh to the
s theta coordinate system okay so
in the in the uh i'm not going to draw
that again so in the s theta system
in the s theta coordinate system
the curvature
is given by
d theta t s okay
so uh you identify first of all you
observe that how i mean just by choosing
a different coordinate system
this s theta coordinate system how the
expression of the curvature
uh it is just even visually much
simplified compared to this uh rather
complicated looking expression
okay now that is about the
left hand side now from the right hand
side what we have
on the right hand side we have this half
dw dx
square and remember in the in the in the
previous video
when we were talking about the
alternative formulation we had already
noted and justified that half d w d x
square is uh equal
to um minus d u s d
x okay so this was about the
on this was about the lhs okay so
from the rhs what we have is
uh this half
d w d x square
that is equal to
d u s d x but with a negative sign
now uh
how can we use this thing okay so
uh you note that
if i consider if i consider the
integration
of this okay uh so
you see the the only difference if i
just consider the integration of this is
the first variation
so we'll deal with that later okay so
uh if we consider the integration of
this
perhaps there is some hope that
it could be written in terms of the
s and theta because after the
integration is done
perhaps you can write this in terms of
the l l and the delta l in those terms
so let us let us proceed in a systematic
fashion
uh and see what what can be done about
this
okay so what i'll say first of all is
that
uh since we have this thing to be equal
let me actually write the equal to sign
here
okay since this is equal
equal to this
if i consider this integration
if i consider this integration
from 0 to l 0 to l
you know that immediately this thing
is
uh nothing but delta l
okay this is nothing but delta l
now uh
if you're a little bit careful uh and
very
very observant you will see that
okay i have written it like this uh
but in the previous video what we had
uh really written or found out
was something a little bit different
okay so let me just show you what's the
difference
okay you have this thing uh
this e u s d x d x all that is fine
we have an integration also uh
but there is the limit okay this limit
is l minus delta l that is not quite the
same here okay
of course it's a negative sign also
involved but that's not the issue here
what i wanted to show was that
there is l minus delta l here so
this delta l is uh so i'm just showing
you again
so previously what we had shown
was that this integration 0 to
l minus delta l due as dx
that is equal to minus of delta l okay
or the other way around
and what we are saying now is that
this thing with the 0 to l that is equal
to delta l so there is a little bit of a
mismatch okay
so i have cheated a little bit okay
a bit of mismatch with what we had shown
earlier
however uh we'll see that it doesn't
really cause much of a problem
uh only because uh especially if
this delta l is not too large okay
now
the good news however is that this
delta l up we have already obtained
uh we have already written earlier in
terms of the
s and theta okay so you see what we are
trying to get at
in the left hand side by identifying
that this delts d square w d x
square is an approximation of the
curvature of the beam
we have written that curvature in terms
of the s and theta coordinate system
in terms of this d theta d s on the
right hand side whatever there is
whatever geometrical arguments we are
talking about ultimately we should be
able to write this thing
in some form involving the s and theta
so how can we do that
okay so we have already done the done
the work regarding that
so let me just go back and
show you in the previous video
we have already obtained this expression
this delta l is equal to
this thing okay so uh
there was a little bit of a mistake here
uh
because when we go from this 0 to l
minus delta
l dx and we change the limit to ds
it should actually be l because you see
this s is going like this
so and make that correction
here when we are writing in terms of the
x
here that is fine but this should be in
terms of 0 to l
here ok all right so
what we'll do is
we'll write this delta l
as
ts minus
0 to l ts
cos theta okay
now the left hand side is in terms of
this
d theta d s okay and the right hand side
is in terms of this
but please note that this we have to
take care of this first variation
and on the left hand side also we have
to take care of this first variation
which is present here
so let us put everything together in the
next slide
so
0 to l e i
let's check what we have we have d
square w d x square
that is the curvature and that can be
written as d theta d s so let's write
that
d theta e s
next we have this d squared delta w d x
square which is basically just the first
variation of d squared w
d x square so this can be written again
as d delta theta
d s we have basically just taken the
delta of d theta d s and taken this
first variation inside the
differentiation okay
so this is this is all set the left hand
side
the right hand side let's check
we have this t this p can go out of this
integration no problem there
so we have this half
delta d w d x square okay
and we have just seen that uh this half
d
w d x square is this entire thing so
what we really have to do
is take the delta of this entire thing
keep keeping in mind that the p
should be also outside okay so let's do
that
so e goes outside we take
the delta
of this whole thing whatever we have
obtained here
that is 0 to l ts
minus 0 to l
d s cos theta
so
this left hand side we are again going
to carry out an integration by
parts
that leaves us with this delta theta in
this boundary terms
minus integration zero to l
d d s of e i
d theta d s
so that's the differentiation on the
first bit
and then we have this delta theta
this is my entire left hand side after
the integration by parts
and on the right hand side if i carry
out this first variation you see this
term is just the l okay the 0 to lds
that is just the capital l
so that's a given to us there is no
question of variability in it
so the first variation of that is
certainly zero so
uh that leaves us with uh
with this uh minus
of our delta zero to l ds cos theta
and what we are going to do is we are
going to take this delta inside
uh this delta is going to operate on
this cos theta
okay so since in terms of operation
uh the delta or the ordinary derivative
or the ordinary differentiation
uh differential it or it acts in the
same way
so what we are going to have is the
s ps
minus sine theta
delta theta
all right so overall
what we are obtaining is
just this let me let me just write it
out here itself
okay so basically what is going to
happen is this this minus
and this minus it becomes a plus okay
so
i just have this all right
so this is an integration on the left
hand side with respect to s
having this delta theta on the right
hand side i have another integration
with respect to s
and it contains in the integrand this
delta theta so
uh for for my governing differential
equation
governing differential equation what i
will have
is this term or this integration
considered together with this thing
and then we take the coefficient of this
delta theta
which is e i
d square theta d s square
please note that i have considered this
e and i to be
in variant or constant with respect to s
so i'm taking this out of the
differentiation
and then i have this plus sorry i forgot
the p
here that mistake plus p
sine theta that is equal to
0 because there are no other terms
involving the integration with respect
to s
and for the boundary conditions you
please note
that we have only just
this now one term uh involving the
boundary so
at x equal to 0
and x equal to l
what we have is either
e i d theta
t s is equal to 0
or theta is specified
okay so this set of equations that we
have obtained this governing equation
together with these boundary conditions
these are said to be the equations of
the elastica
and you please note that how in the
entire procedure
okay so when once we have obtained this
kind of a statement using the calculus
of variations
the obtaining the governing differential
equations and the boundary conditions
that
could be done in a nice mathematical
fashion without even worrying about
the actual uh physical setup okay
we don't even have a real physical setup
in our hand
uh unless we have been given an actual
problem
which of course we'll take in the in the
next video but uh
we have done this in a nice analytical
fashion
okay so it would be nice to have a
little interpretation about this
so what is going on here is that uh this
theta is specified means that
the either the slope is specified okay
or if the slope is not specified then
what we'll have is this e i d theta d s
equal to zero
okay so you think about what what this
thing is really
uh telling us okay so this is the
remind you that this d theta d s itself
is just the curvature
okay so uh
there is your hint you think about what
this d theta d
s the curvature would be in terms of r
the radius of curvature and then uh see
what that
e i divided by the radius of curvature
denotes okay so i've almost given you
the answer but you think about it anyway
all right so ah with that we have our
our uh a more exact version of
the buckling formulation and
using this we can um
solve some problems and that is exactly
what we'll do in the
next class we'll solve one problem okay
and that will teach us a lot of uh
some some big lessons okay all right on
that note i'll end this video thank you
very much